This episode is supported by the great
courses plus Terperi is not the ideal This episode is supported by the great
way to study for an exam, but you are here courses plus Terperi is not the ideal
You've come to this video for sure with a way to study for an exam, but you're here
exam tomorrow or in a couple of hours let's you come to this video for sure with one
Focus on what you can do to optimize the exam tomorrow or in a few hours then let us
your time. How can you effectively hone your focus on what you can do to optimize
before your exam? You may not have your time. How can you effectively hint
Learn a lot, but you can save a lot before your exam? You may not
information in your short-term memory. Learn a lot, but you can save a lot
Try using the ancient technology information in your short-term memory.
"Memory Palace". Dated back to before Christ Try using the ancient technique
this technique involves associating "memory palace". Dated back to before Christ
Ideas you would like to remember with memorable this technique involves associating
places like your home. In a study, ideas you would like to remember had memorable
medical students created memory palaces places like your home. In one study had
To help them remember the effect of insulin medical students created memory palaces
For example, in this example, you can save to help them remember the effect of insulin
glycolysis in your living room and In this example you can, for example, save
ketogenesis in the kitchen. Then you can glycolysis in your living room and
Mentally travel through your house to ketogenesis in the kitchen. Then you can
remember each room. Those who make mental palaces mentally travel through your house to
Manages significantly better remember each room. Those who make memory palaces
in test than those who do not and the reason is performing significantly better
for that is our visual and ours in test than those who do not and the reason
Spatial memory is reasonably strong and for that is our visual and ours
connecting information to the already spatial memory is reasonably strong and
Existing memories turn out to be extremely connected to information already
effectively. You should also use mnemonic existing memories to prove to be extreme
aids whenever possible. Try it effectively. You should also use mnemonics
to remember the citric acid cycle? Take assistive devices whenever possible. Try it
the beginning of each product and one to remember the citric acid cycle? Roof
phrase out of it! the beginning of each product and low one
[Can you throw large stones against Oskar] statement out of it!
You can also create things like rhythms [Can you throw large stones against Oskar]
or songs. This method has been proven in You can also create things like rhythms
Several studies as a way of tying or singing. This method has been proven in
information for memory and the more strange several studies as a way to bind
you can make them the better! Involve your information into memory and the stranger
exam preparation re-reading notes you can make them the better! Involve yours
and books? You are not alone, but you are exam preparation reloading of notes
should stop it. In a study and books? You're not alone, but you
read participants an educational text. should stop it. In a study
A group was then asked to re-read readers an educational text.
the text once again while the other A group was then asked to read it again
group only read it once. They were the text once again while the other
then tested with a multiple choice group only read it once. They became
short-answer questions and text summaries then tested with a multiple choice,
to measure their ability to short-answer questions and text summaries
preserve the information. The experimenters to measure their ability to
found no significant difference in preserving the information. Eksperimentatorene
the performance between the two groups. found no significant difference in
Reloading thus does not give any clear execution between the two groups.
advantage. Although we know that examinations are To re-read, so no one gives clear
stressful, so put some energy into benefits. Although we know exams are
stress relieving while studying and under stressful, so put some energy into it
your exam. Stress causes your body to stress while you are studying and under
produce adrenaline that increases your exam. Stress causes your body to
heart rate and can make you sweat. produce adrenaline that increases your
About 20 min after feeling stressed heart rate and can make you sweat.
undergoes your body a delayed About 20 minutes after feeling stressed
reaction which releases the hormone cortisol. undergoes your body a delayed
Cortisol attaches to receptors on reaction that release the hormone cortisol.
The hippocampus, which is a seahorse-shaped cortisol, attaches to receptors on
part of your brain. It is part of the hippocampus, which is a seahorse-shaped
limbic system and that is the hippocampus part of your brain. It's part of it
who is responsible for low limbic systems and that is the hippocampus
short-term memory to long-term memory that is responsible for low
but when cortisol binds to short-term memory into long-term memory
The hippocampus damages the retraction but when cortisol binds to it
memory. So if you are stressed the hippocampus damages it
You will have harder memory. So if you are stressed out
Recall information during an exam, so you will have more difficulty with
Take some deep breaths! But just to forget about recalling information during an exam, then
Stress is easier said than done. Take some deep breaths! But just to forget
That's why you need a technique to study stress is easier said than done.
which is stress free. Scientists That's why you need a technique to study
recommend testing yourself. which is stress free. scientists
Exercise tests are not only scientifically recommended to test yourself.
Proven Way to Improve Memory Exercise tests are not only scientific
But they help to deal with stressful proven way of improving memory
situations. Scientists found out that when they do help to cope with stress
individuals used exercise tests and subsequent situations. Scientists found out when
were put into stressful situations, they managed individuals used exercise tests and subsequently
as well as those put into stressful situations, they did
was not in a stressful quote. MRI as good as those
studies have also proved that exercise tests were not in a stressful quote. MRI
Increases the ability of the hippocampus to study has also proved that exercise tests
connecting to other parts of the brain increases the ability of the hippocampus to
So even though cortisone can harm some connect to other parts of the brain
lanes, exercise tests can help so even though cortisone can hurt some
to create new paths around the blockages. lanes, exercise tests can help
Do you feel distracted? Try a little to create new roads outside the block stores.
workout. Studies show that those who feel distracted? Try a little one
have exercised for 15 minutes and then workout. Studies show that those who
performs a memory task, manages it to exercise for 15 minutes and then
significantly faster than anyone performing a memory task can do it
did not exercise. Even a simple walk can significantly faster ones ones
make a difference. But you also don't have to exercise. Even a simple walk can
Take a moment and think about the way make a difference. But you should also t
you personally study best. Take a moment and think about that way
Metacognition is the analysis of you personally studying best.
one's own learning and thought process. metacognition is the analysis of
Studies have shown that students with their own learning and thought process.
poor metacognitive abilities - ie Studies have shown that students participate
they do not know their own poor metacognitive abilities - ie
Pieces and weaknesses - generally they fail to know their own
poorer in test. So look inward in ways pieces and weaknesses - generally do
You have been effective before and worse in tests. So look inward in ways
implement these strategies. If you know you have been effective before and
that working alone works best for you implementing these strategies. If you know
So don't go to the common terpertime. that working alone works best for you
with your classmates. It's a busy time! So don't go to the common terpertime.
There is also another lot with your classmates. It's a busy time!
important note to make. There is also another lot
If you try to make far-reaching important note to do.
at night because you know very little if you try to go far
about a topic for your upcoming exam? night because you know very little
Do you hope to refine one already on a topic for your upcoming exam?
strong base of knowledge? Hope to refine one already
GO TO BED! strong base of knowledge?
There are more than a century's worth of studies GOING IN BED!
That proves that sleep is essential for There is more than a century's worth of research
memory. But if you really prove that sleep is essential
is pressed for time memory. But if you really
Consider cradling yourself asleep. It is true! One is pressed for time
study showed that participants who slept consider to cradle yourself asleep. It is true! One
on a bed made to cradle examination showed that participants asleep
fell asleep much faster on a bed made to cradle
slept deeper and did better in memory fell asleep much faster
exercises the next morning, so "rockabyebaby" slept deeper and did better in memory
actually works! Of course if you want to exercise the next morning, then "rockabyebaby"
Avoid Terrorism Next Time and Get Ahead Actually! Of course if you want
Or just learn something completely to avoid the terror next time and get ahead
New, check out today's sponsor or just learn something completely
The Great Courses Plus out. it's a new one, check out the sponsors today
subscription on-demand video learning service The Great Courses Plus out. it is a
with lessons and courses from subscription on-demand video learning service
top professors from around the world with lessons and courses from
Looking for more tips to get top professors from around the world
as much as possible out of your brain Looking for more tips to get
will recommend "optimizing Brain Fitness" as much as possible out of your brain
taught by Professor Richard Restack will recommend "optimizing Brain Fitness"
which contains 12 lessons taught by Professor Richard Restack
Including "how to feed your brain", "enhance which contains 12 lessons
your working memory "and" practice for inclusion "how to feed your brain", "enhance
peak performance ". With a library of over your working memory and practice for
11,000 video lessons on all peak performance. "With a library over
who interests you. science, mathematics, history 11,000 video lessons around everything
literature or how to cook, plays chess that interest you. science, mathematics, history
or become a better photographer. It's a literature or how to cook, play chess
great service. The Great Courses Plus or become a better photographer. It is a
gives our viewers a free sample of great service. The Great Courses Plus
You can show your ASAPscience your support by visiting giving our viewers a free sample
TheGreatCousesPlus.com/ASAPScience You can view your ASAPscience support by visiting
use the link TheGreatCousesPlus.com/ASAPScience
in the description below to begin using the link
your free trial today in the description below to begin
and abbonomer to get more weekly science videos your free trial today
every Thursday and abbonomer for more weekly science videos